sometimes a defeat can really be a
victory let's begin with this puffer
fish minding its own business in this
calm River Delta in Tanzania Africa
enter the predator in this case a river
otter cousin to the Yellowstone sliders
it's trying to make an afternoon snack
out of the puffer fish huh how tough can
it be the otter captures the puffer and
well sort it I mean you know not exactly
okay the truth is the puffer gulps water
until it resembles a beach ball and in
the process transforms from a tasty
morsel into a major pain no matter what
the otter tries the puffer refuses to
deflate himself naturally the otter
appears baffled he set out to get a fish
dinner and instead he seems to be
playing a ball game the irony here is
that the puffer is protecting both of
them the puffer has a poisonous
gallbladder
if the otter actually ate the puffer
they both died Puff Daddy survives and
the otter goes in search of another meal
it can sink its teeth into